alors enfin moi peut-être un peu parler
d'échec ça va aller plus vite donc ça va
être marrant donc ces quatre qualifiés
ce g3 direct la patronne aussi une sorte
de catalan au sapin touche ton clan des
mais c'est pas idiot on est donc la
sicile est parti pour pâques et des cinq
sens tu peux enfin des cortots cavalli a
déversé 6ème c'est du coup sûr à b5 le
thème du cac valeo 5
ouais bon temps en burqa et des cinq
mais bon non non je débute un peu et là
du coup ces cinq ils en profitent pour
pour tenir la casse ces 4es et se
développer cavaliers ces trois hommes et
du coup tu crois peut-être pas des
cadeaux peut-être quand ça ne change
quoi peut-être eu avec rock b3 pouvait
ne tuez le double enquête one way
torcéen et envoie ses projets de fin de
concession qui étoit streisand peut
jouer que quatre aussi le cadre des
trois fautes 3 c'est un truc comme ça ça
dépend savoir qu'on veut b5 tu vas le
faire des trois roues et 310 champions
et non tu peux pas te faire plein de
choses très souple mais tu peux aussi
jouer les capes des fois rock des cadres
et à une bonne version star est bien
faire tourner un temps à te rendre un
peu sur la bien comme il faut quand même
bon ça dépend de ce que font les noms
tout cas ma muse qui réfléchit femmes en
tout début de partie comme ça dans une
cadence si courte tête impression bailly
en fait il a raison que lacan ces
courtes sans être si courte que ça c'est
du g5 + 3 sarah test le temps de
souffler c'est pas du bullet et mais
elle s'impose pas d'ailés ouais mais
disons ce serait idiot de faire une
faute si tôt et de se retrouver mal et
tu vas enfin il a raison on ne serait
pas de chance non mais c'est bien dans
mes manières contre maxime ont pas été
gagnant il ça et là ils expliquent pas
fan mais pourquoi restez-vous plus
lentement que né pour en en longue
jusqu'à cinq minutes a pendu j'ai le
temps des bouffons de ces aides mais
file a quand même claqué mythe 40 1
ouais mais tout pourquoi pas
[Musique]
sûrement rock non des cadets 4 bon ben
ça c'est juste normal des 4 way de bsb
des champions en trois ans n'a cependant
pas le temps de quelques infos f4 aux à
cause de 5 j'imagine sur mon nom je
voulais clair qu'un intermédiaire j'aime
bien les intérêts non mais juste tu
reprends turc et tuchan vit-on fou
autour c1 et tu crois que les gens aient
envie de prendre trop vide en fait ils
peuvent attendre
tu prennes pour développer en même temps
le festival où elle a pris lui-même ok
mais je sais pas ce qu'est le refrain
trois mois de décalage et 4 ont leur pib
3 tout à fait j'avais trois est fou des
six ro rog auquel vont pas du tour des
uns ou ressortir le fou enfin pour
savoir autour de moi je me dis peut-être
est-ce qu'un jour je n'ai pas une heure
une bonne case devient probable
non c'est pour avoir un chip au un jour
de quelque chose ça peut mais du coup je
conçois qu'il a résolu tous les
problèmes juste à vue d'oeil parce que
vous savez toi et ta pas de champion b
de boeuf ou b sat
donc c'est très différent la partie
d'avant on tape v5 et tout ça et tu
verras pas de perdre du temps que la
torah vite et il ya de quoi faire un
petit truc avec les blancs peut-être
même à quatre à cinq feux trois tours
c'est un fouet avoir quelques petites
pressions à pour le joueur chinois fu et
bon tu as dû se fout des deux est ce que
je peux faire un truc de fou winger
fouet trois fous prend un tour assez 1 à
west ham
mais est ce que il veut tellement
prendre cette rencontre mais je sais pas
pourquoi il a mis son faux bond il a
fait [ __ ] avait déjà way et joue très
vite di grassi mais c'est promis je vous
était bien une fille les bons conseils
conseil de mur tu as suivi à 100% voire
joueurs chinois et peut-être mur tu as
derrière a finalement laissé magna peace
& love sylvanus conseil vite et bien
progressé a joué des bons un web mais tu
as et surtour b8 peut-être de fait mais
ramé fois sept tours à huit bombes
tombées les foules mais bon a déjà dû
gagner un tour dans l'histoire tout à
fait c'est bien mais en plus
j'ai tout raté il est bien le chinois il
est bien de chinois fab le joueur
chinois qui obtient une position
avantageuse expression un peu de
pression et mais très chargé pour les
non en fait ça c'est parce qu'il avait
pour le vent tu fais torah c'est un peu
cette fraude et 4,7 a besoin tu peux
enlever tadam il ya des petites
découvertes jouer des finales tu rentres
et n'auront pas la connexion entre les
tours donc toi c'est des problèmes et le
cahier b3 peut être très pénible pour
les rangs à 5 dans les finales aussi et
magnus qui réfléchit magnus qui est mal
autant magnus qui est dans le dur allait
améliorer la vie des travailleurs
inverse
mais bon et il doit il doit lui rester
on n'a pas les secondes qui sait gagner
dû à leur restait moins d'une minute
trente et n'oublie pas que c'est pas du
5 + 3 s'étaient déguisés les auquel les
singles bonin piotta tu veux juste faire
faut des quatre aussi là pour juger
l'action
tu peux aussi faire [ __ ] en d5 et
prendre le pion oui tu peux prendre que
les jeunes ne peut-être en gare de u17
une 17 pour le joueur n'empêche
norvégien champion du monde mais qui va
peut-être enfin ne pas gagner un tournoi
non il ya déjà pas gagné le rapide et
blitz ruiner en longue ça fait un moment
qu'ils gagnent alors ces cinq jouable
pas ce qui a ébranlé prend des cinq plus
d'intervenir à turku mais n'ont pas fait
attendre
c'est beau la cfa ben oui mais d'une
pédagogie fab exceptionnelle avec
l'attak découverte sur le cavalier la
dame partout fap qui échauffe abfab de
gala aujourd'hui fabre venise oui j'ai
considéré être tous les ans alors je me
suis vite on s'est un peu savent aussi
mais en fait juste ok on va voir parce
que tu as donné ton soutien de mon choix
oui mais tiéné 5 mai l'avocate va gagner
le pion doit peut-être mon travail en
plus
mais les finales seront pas si simple à
gagner je sais pas s'il faut prendre
soin qu'il fallait faire d'un coup
pratique huld ans qui joue vite et ça
c'est plutôt bon signe parce que femme
je vraiment souligner mais la cadence
délai on ne peut pas être gagnée de
temps mais tu as beau
trente secondes en délaisser pas comme
j'aime pas de rim j'ai déjà dit je sais
plus mais je sens mais le pas du tout
plaquer et français étaient 5 va forcer
je vais le mettre force l échange des
dames et les blancs qui ont cabine final
très avantageuse pape ne soyons pas
c'est bien mais tout ça souvent la peur
de fou ça peut commencer un pion dans
les gants mais marchal dans plein de
finale et c'est pas si simple quoi c'est
pas si simple
cependant ces ding qui met la pression
mais ça fait bien longtemps qu'on n'a
pas vu minutes car c'est mon danger dans
un départage femme parce que ma
condition qui gagne absolument tous les
départager là on voit quand même qu'il
est vraiment pas en grande forme il est
pas en train d'écraser ding
quoi qu'il en soit même si sortait
gagnant du match il aura pas écrasé non
en rapide il n'a rien montré et là en
blitz est plutôt le joueur chinois qui
pour le moment dominé mais se sera pas
c'est pas un cavalier seul en tout cas
du joueur norvégien et les cavaliers
seuls c'est plutôt ce à quoi il nous a
transmis qu'à pas s'il a déjà perdu mais
quand je dis cavalier seul je parle pas
d'un cavalier seul sur l'échiquier
je parle bien de l'expression faire
cavalier seul assez bien ce qu'il faut
dire qu'en plus il est déjà l'heure de
jeu pas accepter voilà il fait pas alors
est-ce qu'on peut mettre un cas vaillant
17 peut-être fab et suivi des tours sur
ces 7 pour essayer de te forcer
justement à te séparer de ton coup de
canne blanche pourtant fermé te mettre
en boîte j'ai envie de dire un petit peu
tu sais comme comme les haricots en
boîte
beaucoup ont beau poème de f-35 long
métrage me dire tu fais toi tu rêves de
1 km et tu défends tu défends enfin f3
tu as tu eu droit à deux typhons et deux
tapis de maths avec des fois je crois
machin et devra peut-être faire le 4 et
20 chez bas salaires norman toit cinq
tours 3
il veut que non mais c'est la place et
harmonium
oui mais il ya un manque de mes bons
tessin à trévignon et tu fais tu es en
train d'être un fou et cinq sur tempo
je sais pas j'ai fait mais bon le joueur
le joueur norvégien n'a plus que 25
secondes fabre 25 secondes pour la
norvège
la norvège en difficulté face à la chine
le relais du joies du joueur chinois qui
fait mal quand il fait quoi avec sept
tours
attention à la tour qui est menacée ce
qu'on fait tous en fait tour cc3 qui
paraît quand même le coup un mois jour
est la logique cavaliers detroit j'y
crois pas du tout je crois pas une
seconde tour d2 je sais pas assez manque
d'armes d'armes mais pour ces trois
tours des huit le joueur chinois qui à
mon avis laissez-passer passagers encore
une partition davantage jouer cette tour
en trois ans on sait pas trop ce qu'elle
fait pas revenus en d2 mais cette tour
en 3 effet pas grand chose bizarre un
joueur chinois qui est fort en défense
qui tient bien mais c'est peut-être son
défaut de presser les avantages mais
temps mais ce front collé à l'oreille je
vais trottoir opposé ça ça va faire nul
n'aura pas sûr loin de là loin de là tu
nous lâche une info s'est pas encore nul
mais à mon avis ça s'en approche le
joueur chinois qui m'intéresse en otage
à la pendule et tu vas faire histoire ce
cas tu sais pas bloqué comme autrefois
quand même bon il va quand même avancé
c'est vrai ok tu fais à 3 tu dois faire
à 3 tu dois essayer de garder un pion
sur la dame qui soutiendra le fou qui
sera soutenue et d'envoyer les pions
avec trois ou quatre têtes une tour qui
pourra à partir des trois feux new wave
4 froid je pensais que trois ou quatre
oies f2 il faut faire mal et il va
falloir mettre une tournée dans des
tirades un devoir à ces bagarres donc
c'est plus dur à suivre
on va faire revoir les rafales de coups
donc rafale de coups c'est un peu comme
le mistral souffle fort il met le pion
h4 alors fab pronostics j'ai envie de
dire quel quel pourcentage de son ski
voilà c'est simple la question non mais
tu me fais 60 40 60 40 pour les nuls
pour ding paris fatigué brochand deux
nuls mais ouais ok donc 60% de nuls 40 %
de gain pour diane en un an pendant dix
ans a annoncé déjà plus du 80 20 à 80%
chances de nuit 20% de chance pour pour
dingli reine de gagner dingli rennes qui
a sa majorité à la droite qui va devoir
envoyer un jour ou l'autre là de toute
façon il faut y aller mais il pourra
peut-être regretter fab ce tour cinq
tours 3 tout à fait là j'ai l'impression
que non lieu des 4,5 ou des services
tu passes un peu ton roi des fois de
plus accusé qualité cela non sur la
tombe et trois trous b3 et foods 2 1 qui
va arriver et donc ses efforts à un toit
au pire enfin empêche la presse ait fait
tout retour à 7
alors allez il faut il faut faire
quelque chose pour le joueur chinois ici
pas grand chose à faire mais il faut
trouver femmes il faut trouver non mais
il doit pousser peut pas faire du baril
doit repousser la montagne ne peut pas
accouché d'une souris ici il faut
pousser ses gags déjà
voila voila j'ai gagné quatre fois lâché
4 à fond il peut vouloir faire qui on
prend qui on prend envoyez peut-être h5
je sais pas fermer quelque chose bonjour
bon non mais bon un jour tu fais fausse
histoire et fit matin vidéo il faut
avoir un petit peu d'imagination aussi
c'est important mais il peut y avoir des
h6 qui traînent atteindre au f5
bon je fais tourner même fou et 6 3 et 4
c'est là non je suis là cette façon tu
peux pas remonter autant dans cette
cadence fable et ses sautes de la mer m
2 ils échangent encore des pions ah ok
il va falloir faire ou f 4g et 5g six
mètres peut-être un fou sur des crânes
admettre un pion à landing
allez on pousse on pousse le joueur
chinois qui est est en train de prendre
le dessus fab
non mais sans son tour au 1/8 sa
commence c'est pas que ça prenne forme
mais aussi quelques jours foucault a
posé comme ça c'est des matches à dire
est qu'il faut aussi semé la pagaille
leroy qui valent à battre angers 5 g si
c'était très mal et le roi qui est en
train d'être d'être complètement
déportés vers les dames
et si un jour on échange et les tours
maintenant fab et qu'on réussissait avec
les blancs affaires à faire rager 6
rapidement pourrait gagner de plongée et
gagner la finale qui serait gagnante 1
si on gagne le plonger qui appelait tous
ces gagnants
si on met un fou en d4 ces gagnants ça
peut être un petit peu compliquée pour
le joueur norvégien mais il est champion
du monde fabien est donc ce sera pas une
mince affaire pour pour le chinois que
de gagner cette finale tout à fait bon
j'ai six jouets ou là il ya des réseaux
maintenant peut-être même un plan tout
bête indre année laurent 1,3 faire foot
et 4 mai même suffire le roi noir qui
semblait en difficulté à me fous des
caps tu peux faire un coup d'éclat c'est
avec quatre tours tourcoing des
catéchèses - mais peut-être un comme moi
j'ai trois des six fausses
s'il faut cinq exactement il semble il
semble que le chinois frappe le premier
à la femme c'est ça en grand moment
qu'on est en train de vie ça fait très
longtemps que magnus n'a pas n'a pas été
en danger dans des partages ne vous êtes
jamais peut-être jamais est fou d66
trouve le coup de fabien 10 visages qui
met ya peut-être fou de ici on mettra le
feu au sein qui semble que magnus soit
au bord du précipice maintenant six
secondes c'est un peu comme comme dans
les dessins animés tabbee bip le coyote
et le coyote cours f
pas de chance oui ou alors les
précipices ils ont eu à courir garder
sous la main je suis tombé au pied bise
à l'essai sans doute plus simple
ouais je lui donnais page 5 pourquoi
at-il de nash 5 peut-être qu'ils
craquent tu fasses non mais c'est
sûrement juste gagner encore ça se voit
pas ce que tu vas prendre g7 ont laissé
passer tu fais le raisonnement passe au
charisme fabien face au charisme du
joueur norvégien et non mais le charisme
choses importantes
un charisme important attention à pas
faire de pâtes mais pour le moment ça ça
semble aller c'est ça va mais tu vois
que pareille peut y avoir des réseaux de
patin jour on sait jamais comme vous
fait de pièces comme ça mais oui mais
regarde ça c'est pas gagné
je pense que c'est un peu plus simple
tout à l'heure non mais se bat à fond
magnus magnus très défend très très bien
il bouge pas de six secondes quoi ouais
ding qui a qui a peut-être craqué en
tout cas s'il rate nom mêlé doit gagner
ces rachats de positions l'avantagent
qui est monté à un moment donné à +14
meding maintenant qu'ils qui a du mal à
conclure
est ce que le joueur chinois a ce qu'il
faut
fabien pour mettre en danger et
déstabiliser finalement le norvégien
bah écoute sa niche ou quoi mais là mais
bon il joue il joue mais mais pour
bouygues gagne pas le fou ces cas qui
contrôle la casse g8 j'ai bien
l'impression qu'un défaut et c'est
d'ailleurs et ce roi du mur en est
maintenant à neuville ce tu fais des
choses qu'il ne réussira pas à
l'emporter fabien bonsoir je pense pas
peut-être qu'il faut réussir à faire
tout à fait tous rêvent scène même sa c3
g8 et pousse ses pions et je pense qu'il
n'y arrivera pas il a plus assez de
temps il n'a pas il n'a pas la caisse
dynamique aimez la paille la fin de quoi
mais mais il lui manque le tu vois et
maintenant il ya coup des trois
peut-être
quel bon torje 5,5 ou peut-être ouais
mais attention attention fabien le
joueur le joueur chinois qui nous déçoit
un petit peu un finir il avait plié avec
arsène a indiqué rien défendu je pense
oui mais bon laisser aux fourrages ça
c'est quand même assez incroyable à
résister par tu veux trop gagner trop
vite quoi t'es trop excités et aux
chrétiens je finis et en fait il fit n'a
rien d'utopique finale bon il reste bien
il karl avantage peut-être faire du tour
c'est 3 et 6 expliqué roy poussé g7 mais
bon pour lui il faudrait mieux que le
temps se rajoute le problème est là le
délai plutôt father de magnus qui la
victoire pourquoi les victoires on ne
sait pas en tout cas ces cris 1 0 on
veut notre je sais pas pourquoi il
manque peut-être des coups mais on pris
corps du joueur chinois apparemment ça
eu la caisse alors qu'a eue la caisse
wording a perdu autant qu il a perdu en
temps incroyable incroyable il est tombé
donc vous confirmez dire le no fake un
magnus est tombé magnus est tombé
incroyable manu ce qui est vraiment pas
en forme
fabien maintenant c'est dire s'il se
prend 2,7 canon scié très stressante
mais il s'assoit près aussi la série des
sages obtiendra les petites allez c'est
parti donc à grignols hockey avec
détroit la plupart dans un marché
espagnol rare ce que ça donne ouais je
voudrais tu fais après la porte et on
s'est passé c'est idiot là qui sont
dehors la fin oui je ferme la porte chez
toi on est à fond dedans femmes une
espagnole c'est à spécialité la
spécialité de fabien le grand maître
français fabien ibiza justice qui aime
bien les espagnols
non mais c'est très intéressant l'espère
parce que c'est juste une ouverture avec
l'instructeur possible mais peu sont
très riches
et voilà ça c'est cool donc qu'est ce
que ça donne la pole man fab tes
premières impressions la source est
espagnol qu'en penses tu que qui que se
passe-t-il nombre appréciable
non ça c'est classique monde et pour
cela il va prendre le centre a ils ont
poussé carrément appris de l'espace
alors ça va
il va essayer de faire je pars à 4,1
jours affaiblit la structure des noirs
là bas et pourquoi pas rentrer sur la
colonne c'est peut-être un avant-poste
ans et 6 donc avoir contre tu fais ça
quoi mais pour l'instant b4 en fait tu
adores a calé en vsat et tu le met hors
jeu mais pas en saignant c4 donc tu peux
pas c'est pas l'heure mais avec votre
post ans vaincu s'il joue beaucoup plus
vite que la partie d'avant tout cas même
et il a fait part d' il derrière la
partie précédente sur la pendule au
final ce qui s'est mis très mal autant
d'ailleurs il est tombé
ben non oui mais vraiment en fait mais
oui
non mais il était trop le temps mais non
mais il était moins bien très vite après
l'ouverture en fait ouais c'est pas
juste l'avant de l'udc est tombé ce top
20 mais il apparaît que en fait s'il
avait été juste mal après l'ouverture
comme il avait 4 alors les 4 à 5
oui mais à droite un peu tu n'as pas le
temps on va le montrer ce que c'est très
pédagogique des cats qui bloque le
cavalier donc qui coupe les oreilles on
avait vu dans une partie de fil rogers
est pas si longtemps et sur 1,5 pas le
temps de faire à trois causes options
prendre si on prend un tour croire ne du
coup tu peux nouveau tempo près c'est
pour ça que dit mürrenfluh k&b s'est
adjugé 4 15 médailles gagnées g4 est
parti mais rien n'est fait fab encore
peut-être que j'ai 4 contre les mains de
magnus
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas en tout
cas ça va être une partie
j'ai envie de dire où cac et prend des
trois c'est pas un peu bizarre surtout
la femme de prendre le fou qui était
peut-être se faire des conneries qu'on
rentrait en c2 et peut-être rbk tfou
beisheim ne pas avoir commencé par b 4
bat être chanceux footeux partir quand
même peut-être on ne lâche pas d'infos
doit il protège
en tout cas je peux te dire j'ai déjà
suivi des blitz je ne sais pas où entre
ding et magnus et ding avait aussi raté
un + 2 qui avait finalement perdu du
temps qu'il a une pression et peut-être
ça peut justement débloquer le joueur
chinois mais c'était un câble aux états
unis n'est que de 10 mètres vache un non
sens qu'un autre donc ça pourrait
savourer le débloquer le joueur chinois
un de gagner se départagent fab contre
le meilleur joueur du monde en départage
la sacem et ne pas faillir linverse un
magnus qui est impérial toujours en
départage
il s'est tu ouais mais ça pourrait ça
pourrait changer des choses dans la tête
des joueurs et surtout la tête de
mindjack il avait redonné cantal
si tu te sens moins vulnérables aux
autres tu peux être faisable uniquement
après tout moi même temps il va il faut
le faire en tout cas pour ding ding qui
doublent sur la colonne c'est comme
l'avait prévu fabien et qui va peut-être
pouvoir s'introduire en c2 ou peut-être
un petit coup comme dame du 3 au 6
femmes pour pour tenter d'échanger les
dames ou kg 6 pourquoi pas et quand il
prend les cases au kg 3 peut-être h5
peut être une idée ici pour jouer sur
quatre ans plus tard ouais pourquoi pas
mais je pense que t'as pas envie de
toucher le roi en photo ont globalement
ouais ok peut-être 320 tu vas faire mais
c'est pas mal al-dam ça va alors en gros
il a bien joué du poisson il contrôle
l'échiquier la dame a peut-être
philibert détroit quand même femme de sa
vie et ses quatre échanges et fourbe et
cinq lectrices ou dessins que veut dire
bah on va remonter un set pour celle à
qui des fous des huit je vois pas dans
quel monde les plans vous gagnez sahin
personnellement bon mais peut-être que
je me trompe pas c'est toi le
spécialiste de l'espagnol tu connais
mieux que moi non mais attendez trop
pourquoi pas que ton fils tu viennes
dame 17
c'est un petit peu surprenant il avait
fait d'un bet5 d'un bessette il veut
quoi ils veulent et c'est là la caf
doivent être fous sur pc café sur kyle
4b 5b 4
la main 8,8 à vis de quelque part et est
rentré tout rappelle donc elle
s'éclatait jouer foulée cinq cavaliers à
5 c'est bien ce qu'ont ce qu'on disait
allez ce qu'il va y avoir un comme
dahmani toulouse mb oui de toute façon
je pensais les deux seuls coûts
possibles pour ne pas perdre la dame
sinon la dame n'a plus de gaz mais pas
embêté 8 alors maintenant est ce que
l'idée est donc vous êtes mieux but je
suis allé sur b4 d'am dam des doors il
menace que pas me prendre b4 peut-être
un coup comme tour ces trois ici femmes
pour couper la connexion va d'ailleurs
coup joué peut-être faire du foot est
rempli ah oui tu foutais 3e du tour des
3 du foot est roi même plutôt affable et
la dame que revenir par la suite mais
attention à cavaler ses 6 1 quand même
qu'il faut à une fourchette
il a peut-être fait refouler 8 en
premier se débarrasser de ce cavalier
donc peut-être à 3 est un coup ici pour
pour les blancs pour re stabiliser le
cavalier à 5 mois au pire tu gères tu
t'en fous mais pas en d3 laurent 80 x 8
peut-être pour garder le contrôle de la
casse et 6 et protéger le pian étudiants
dans les cases 17 livres aussi pour le
cavalier peut-être qu'elle et sa fille
et ses 5 à qui il a pris goût on va
prendre moi mais qu'elle sait si c'est
peut-être une option qui fait mais
pourquoi vous prendront des 5 ou
tourmalet direct je pense vous prendra
le français 3e rang des cinq noms mais
on peut aussi faire tort français six
mois temps on va gagner un tour dans
tous les cas pour la qualité ouais mais
je pense que font des saints qui peut
peut-être raté soit 1,3 et hop dd5
d'attaqué des quatre en tout cas magnus
qui a réussi a finalement obtenir une
position qui joue un puisque à la sortie
de l'ouverture on sentait plutôt ding à
l'aise non mais la manyu cette règle
c'est équilibré mais manu ce qui peut
attaquer une position d'équilibré
ma mère est peut-être trop 8 français 3
pensez-y l'a83 pour 3 francs 6 bon juste
ok tu prends avec avec cette tour il va
te prends tu reprends du foot on
reproche qu'on sait pas trop possible si
tu vas faire ça tu attaques et tu peux
être le centre tu fais des 4 ok là près
du four je sais pas mais peu importe et
et tu as vu que ça fasse et pas
évidentes c'est ta caméra très faible a
expliqué envie et
attention quand même en trombe news je
quitte ou double qui perdait près
céligny ce n'est pas forcément mécontent
de l'évolution de la part de la partie
puisque maintenant la position est
déséquilibré peut-être que les blancs ne
sont pas mis au pas mais en tout cas
c'est position à trois résultats et
c'est exactement ce que je cherchais le
joueur norvégien
alors est-ce que ding est mieux ici juin
je pense que j'y tiens pas clair
l'annoncé face à wiese difficile
d'évaluer
mais magnus qui est un petit peu mieux
autant dans cette partie fabre 40
secondes avance c'est un peu aussi jouer
on va voir il faut que je prendrai les
drames en fait tu prendrais et noir va
passer une info que tu lâches mais
savoir plus facile tu es foulées ça tu
fais des saints avec tata curan non mais
tu fait qu'il prend 4 tu mais j'ai
compris que tu ouvres la diagonale du
fou et une attaque à fond dames à cinq
voitures et fait juste fou bessette et
des cinq au prochain match
j'y vais à fond et ducassou est en tête
des dames à 8 ou si un jour qu'ils
peuvent traîner pour bien d'ouvrir bien
comme il faut on va voir ce que choisit
le joueur chinois ne faut pas des trois
pari dangereux traîne trop break au
plasma talent autant que ça te me sont
compliquées pour calculer des trucs pour
autant qu'il faut jouer avec la main
aussi des fois j'ai peur du mental du
joueur chinois dans cette partie
vraiment quand on disait il peut avoir
lieu
pas avoir du mal un contre magnus et ça
ça peut faire la différence fabien à il
prend le cas donc il joue pas du tout
comme tu l'avais prévu c'est chiant de
ce fou ouais j'aime pas trop ce que fait
ding honnêtement moi ok avec vous à le
prendre pas tu vas pas laisser ce que ce
grand champion
alors il va le prendre ça c'est évident
il avait déjà pris un faux rappeler
qu'on n'a pas le voile il n'a pas pris
la fée g5 intermédiaire qu'on avait
oublié mais viviani laupies 17% l'avait
pas du tout vu en bas
mais j'ai cinq menace le cavalier et le
fou l'emprise donc dia calculé x 8
et apparemment surpris on prend ici si
on arrêtait de faire dame 17 pour s'en
prendre aux rois n'oublions pas qu'un et
chaque perpétuelle bienvenue pour le
joueur chinois gagnent la partie 1
puisque en cas de maladie mais du coup
king avait évidemment baisser la garde
et son fou rire quoi aucun cas et des
sahraouis la position pour ding écrasant
magnus qui fait une mauvaise partie x 7
mai au quai faire là bas tu fais ce que
tu veux te fais ce que tu veux à trop
défendre tout comme ses 7 mai dès 6 ans
et tu prends donc s'est bien battu
amateurs ouais bah pas tout à fait bruit
donc tu regardes c'est vrai que ça et
que ding mériterait la victoire y fait
bon là-dedans sacrifiés il prend prend
prend hélas il faut trouver un bon coup
quel est le truc on le sent une faute
car il faut faire gaffe de ne pas se
prendre un chip haut avec salon de
beauté qui traîne pour un con en tout
cas le joueur le joueur norvégien
qu'aqua matériellement contre les pièces
fab
on a une tour est un fou et un bien et
un pion celle à trois heures contre une
dame dans l'explosion donc à nantes a
bien tout le royaume puis elles sont
coordonnées fait beaucoup de choses bien
pour les pièces dame prend des si c'est
là peut-être fouet 4 simplement de la
salle
carballo cette menace tout rachat matt
savage qui est imparable
bofa bien haut la surprise pas bien la
surprise
magnus qui fait une partie horrible
finalement et qui va se faire mater sur
l'échiquier il nous a pas habitués à ça
depuis un long moment le joueur
norvégien à ses ouailles albanais
incroyable parce qu'on vient de vivre
ensemble en direct
non il a bien joué watts et picasso
thing incroyable fab m'amuse qui es tu
es vraiment pas en formant ce tournoi on
pensait qu'il était revenu après avoir
battu sow et ses maximes coup sur coup
en partie longue les départage on
pensait le voir s'envoler tel un pantani
et finalement il s'est écrasé comment
hincapie
voyez comment hincapie dans la montée
donc félicitations à dean qui gagne ce
match et peut-être qui se débloquent
psychologiquement en face aux champions
du monde
c'est une partie qui peut être important
dans un mini match qui peut être
important dans la carrière il faut
prendre en faute donc bravo à digby
rennes vraiment félicitations à lui
magnifique tournoi et sur fougères je
sais pas là un truc comme vous vous
rangez trois prises par les f-5 en tout
cas peut applaudir robot il y avait une
belle victoire
bravo ding qui avait joué à ses propres
tourments ni la mairie s'était amusé
dans la partie nantes très dur avec son
rock était hyper hyper attaquer et
comptera dans les deux parties du il a
su résister après les faits des belles
victoires
bah écoutez bravo à lui quoi
beau vainqueur 7-5 que schild tiens à
vous remercier
fab d'avoir suivi le championnat de
france et la chine que phil cup c'était
notre compagnon estime valley stream qui
n'arrête jamais toute la journée tous à
vous avez été très très très nombreux à
nous suivre
ça fait très plaisir bien évidemment ce
sera des arguments de diction et chaises
comme priori refaisons refaisons 10
était très heureux si vous avez aimé
bien sûr vous pouvez mettre des
commentaires omar leader somptueux des
achats et de partout et à qui on dit à
bientôt quoi pendant la coupe du monde
on sera de retour et qu'elle veut avant
moi moi je pars en italie donc tu sera
quand même de retour pour le voilà pour
le pour le troisième tour où le
troisième tour et demi
et si vous voulez soutenir tchatche com
et donc aider jazz comme n'hésitez pas à
prendre soin des désabonnements twitch
mais encore mieux des abonnements
diamant voir le site sur le site
recheche comme point fr était plus floue
et sont les puzzles roche illimité trucs
comme ça